-Hey, Jim, welcome to the show
-Wow. Good afternoon, Seth
Thank you.
It's good to be here.
-So I want to ask
about this show...
-Yeah.
-...which is about your fora
into cannabis farming,
but I want to start by asking,
how did you decide
to become a cannabis farmer?
-Totally by accident.
I got this really
sweet little property
on the Rogue River
in Southern Oregon.
And the property behind me
is an 80-acre farm.
And it came up for sale.
I bought it.
And I was like, uh, now what
Uh, hay, alfalfa,
corn, cattle.
And it just so happened
that the cannabis was lega
in the state of Oregon
just that year,
and I went, "Well..."
Got a couple guys,
one Captain Jack who used to b
the weed dealer
at "SNL" in the early '70s
-That's great.
-Yeah.
-That's really exciting
because I do think you worry
that with the legalization
of cannabis
that it might become
a little corporate.
It's really nice to know
that you're working with
a guy named Captain Jack.
-Captain Jack.
Well, there are no corporate
guys in the field.
They're all old-time growers
Old spiritual creatures.
Agriculturalists.
Really natural,
natural ingredients.
The corporate guys kind of cam
in to see where the money is
but...and now I've become
one of them.
-Well, you look --
I will say, you do not --
laying eyes on you,
I am not in any way worrie
that you've gone corporate
You look very --
-[ Laughs ]
You look way more like
a guy who'd be hanging out
with Captain Jack than --
-Yeah.
-Do you name -- do you help name
the different strains, Jim
-Well, I have one -- we have
about six, seven strains.
And one is Captain Jack's,
of course.
We call it the Smell of "SNL."
-[ Laughs ]
-Because that's what it wa
known as back then,
the Smell of "SNL."
Because it was the hallways,
you know, in the early '70s.
-Sure. Sure.
-I have one called Cherry Pi
that I really like, Seth,
because it's a very low THC.
It's like 18%.
But it has like 3% terpenes,
which is the flavor
and the smell.
And with a little bit of CBD
the three of them create wha
they call an entourage effect.
Which is just kind of
this calming,
there's no anxiety
and there's no paranoia.
You can still be chill
and sweet.
Actually, I named it because
I would come downstairs
at night,
and my wife would go,
"Are you hungry?"
I'd go, "Yeah." And she goes
"Let's go out to eat."
"Okay." "What do you have
a taste for?", she'd say?
I went --
well, I'm from Chicago,
I wanted cheeseburgers.
She goes, "Oh, Jim, it's
a little heavy for me.
Anything else?"
"Well, how about some sushi?
"Oh.
I had sushi with my mom
last night.
Anything else?"
"Well, how about if we go to
a natural food --"
"Cilantro, cilantro, cilantro,
they put cilantro everything."
"What are you wasting
my time for?
You know we're going to ea
where you want to eat
and eat
what you want to eat!"
-[ Laughs ]
-So now I take one little hit,
because I'm a microdoser,
I only take one little bit
-Yeah.
-I come downstairs and she says,
"Are you hungry?"
"Yeah."
"You want to go out to eat?"
"Sure."
"Where do you want to go?"
I go, "Baby, we can go
to Taco Bell
as long as you're sitting
across from me.
-Ah, see?
-And she's like --
-What a great
advertisement.
-"Aren't you being charming?
Right?
And so I call that strain
the Marriage Counselor.
-Oh, the Marriage Counselor.
That is...
-I told that story in Oregon
Seth,
and it sold out in two months.
I can't even keep it.
-[ Laughs ]
-Women are coming
into dispensaries --
-Very good marketing.
-And they come into
dispensaries and say,
"Where's that
Marriage Counselor?
He needs some."
And on the other end,
I have a thing
called Black Diamond,
which the veterans really like
because it helps with the PTSD
and pain and sleep.
And especially the PTSD.
And one of my friends
is paralyzed
from the chest down
and his legs go into spasms.
And this Black Diamond
stops those spasms.
And so it's really --
there's a lot of medicinal
properties to this.
And I call that one
Assisted Living.
-That is -- well,
you're obviously providing
a service there.
You're also real world
philanthropic --
you know,
I should say efforts.
Can you talk a little bit abou
the Last Prisoner Project?
Because I think it's a reall
great organization
that's taking into account
that what used to be illegal
is now not, and yet there'
still plenty of people
serving jail time for marijuana.
-Seth, there's 40,000 prisoner
that are serving jail time
for non-violent
cannabis consumption
or possession.
There's a guy named
Michael Thompson in Michigan
I hope the governor of Michiga
is watching this.
Please release him.
He got sentenced
to 40 to 60 years
for having three pounds
of cannabis.
He's been in for 25 years.
He is now -- we wanted
to get him out
because we were scared
for him to get COVID.
He has COVID.
He's in the hospital.
And this should not be
a death sentence
for something that is legal,
it's medicine,
it's non-violent, and there'
thousands of prisoners.
Steve DeAngelo and myself
and a few other people
are on the board,
and we're trying to get
these people out of prison
And it's always -- it's always
been communities of color
subject to the
disappropriateness
of this kind of practices.
And it's --
So I'm part of that.
-That's great that
you're doing that.
This is such a fun show.
It's really cool to see yo
behind the scenes of this farm
and the travels you make t
Colombia among other places.
-Oh, yeah.
-Thanks so much for making -
-I went to Colombia
for nine days with cameras
and improvised
the whole time.
And it's probably the middle
part of our three episodes
It's on Discovery coming u
on Wednesday the 19th.
-Well, I can't wait.
And thank you so much
for making time for us, Jim.
Always a pleasure to see you
-You know, Seth, it's always
a pleasure to see you
and thank you so much
for your time.